we say this a lot but documents obtained
by Judicial Watch may confirm collusion
between Muller and Comey
in the emails FBI officials advise
former director James Comey to consult
with special counsel Muller before Comey
testified to Congress what
well that substantiates News reports
that Comey met with Muller prior to his
testimony before the Senate Intel
committee in June of last year joining
us now with more on this is tom Fitton
the president of Judicial Watch we're
also joined by whitewater deputy
independent counsel Saul Weisenberger
along with Harmeet Dillon at the RNC
committee woman from California a
practicing attorney civil rights
attorney as well great to see all of you
Tom boy it's tough to get documents out
of this Justice Department and you guys
had to file how many suits to get this
nugget about Comey and Muller to federal
lawsuits Freedom of Information Act
lawsuits we again asked began asking for
the documents in August of last year we
just got 15 or so pages in the last week
or so and they show as you say you know
James Comey was fired by the President
and within a day or so he's
communicating with the FBI about
upcoming testimony because all the
Congress wanted them to testify and you
see the emails dear Jim hi Jim can we
coordinate what information do you need
me to have in terms of incident can we
have we have a couple of the full
screens of the emails up there and yeah
director in response to your email below
we've consulted with executive
management here including the general
counsel and recommend the following that
your counsel there's a mistakes there's
typos in here but consult with a special
counsel Muller to determine the timing
of any such testimony so the timing
should be worked out with Muller - right
is there any benign explanation for this
well you know typically there would be
some coordination but what Comey said
was beyond the pale in terms of what
government officials are typically
allowed to say in such situations
certainly if you're an FBI director and
you're having meetings with the
President of the United States typically
the agencies tell you you're not allowed
to talk about it you're not allowed to
talk about documents you created at the
eff
I about those conversations Comey had
full full you know free rein and during
his testimony and it was blessed both by
the FBI it looks like and by mr. Muller
Saul this is curious but they're also as
they refer to in this in this email
there are I guess they say institutional
privileges or prerogatives that may be
presented by any such testimony so the
FBI a special counsel's office messaging
call me about you we just want to
basically coordinated out the concerns I
guess I don't know the institutional
privileges things that call me wouldn't
have to reveal presumably on Capitol
Hill do you see any problems with this
the appearance of coordination I don't
see any problem for for Muller I don't I
don't to me this isn't really new news I
think Comey at the time announced that
he was going to consult with Muller it's
very clear that Comey has had a man
crush on Muller for quite some time and
wants to wrap himself in in Muller's
glory but I haven't actually read these
latest emails that Tom got but I don't
think there's anything wrong with Comey
going to Muller and saying I'm gonna
testify do you have any problem with
what I'm gonna say or how I'm gonna say
it and do we know that Muller blessed
anything or is that just somebody's
surmise so again nothing surprises me
about Jim Comey I don't think it should
be used to smear Muller here's another
big story and Harmy I don't want to get
into this so Devin Nunez and Trey Gaudi
went up to the Justice Department today
and they were allowed to review certain
classified documents and they said this
afterward we had a productive discussion
today with officials at the office of
Director of National Intelligence
Department of Justice FBI and we raised
questions related to the information
requested from the Intel community the
officials committed to holding further
discussions of these matters we look
forward to continuing dialogue blah blah
blah this follows Nunez again
threatening contempt of Congress against
Jeff Sessions simply gift a threatened
contempt of Congress to get anywhere and
you know and what what is this where's
this going I mean this is a this is a
spectacle it does vary
for the reputation of the Department of
Justice and the FBI here where it takes
threats repeated threats it's like you
know it's like those movies where the
villains are chasing the train and
they're throwing stuff off the back to
try to delay them you know it's like
that but eventually they're going to
have to you know pay the piper and come
forward with this information they're
doing it very slowly there's clearly
something they have to hide because if
they didn't have something to hide
what's really ironic here is that the
Department of Justice is not in the
Constitution it's an inferior branch of
government that was created by Congress
and so for them to arrogantly say that
they're somehow above the Congress and
they don't have to answer requests like
the rest of the government is truly
outrageous so the president wants them
to cooperate clearly now they put out
the story at the DOJ that the White
House is on board with with what they're
doing but then the White House put out a
statement saying no actually we want you
to cooperate just don't give stuff
that's extra top high seek top secret
what we've seen from their word actions
in the past that have been grudgingly
unveiled is that there were nothing
burgers they were simply there to
protect and to protect the DOJ from yeah
well they were exculpatory exculpatory
not not for the DOJ right for Flynn and
and you know for other people so they're
protecting very Zarya hide so there's
always a tug of war between Congress and
the executive branch that has always
existed but this does take it to a new
level and Kym's Drossel has an
interesting analysis I want you all to
weigh in on this tonight in the Wall
Street Journal
she writes it's about the FBI source she
says we know mr. Nunez's requests deals
with a top secret and intel source of
the FBI and CIA who is a US citizen and
who was involved in the Russia collusion
probe we might take this to mean that
the FBI secretly had a person on the
payroll who used his or her non FBI
credentials to interact in some capacity
with the Trump campaign stressfull seems
to be she has incredible sources I know
that and she seems to be indicating that
there could have been someone inside the
Trump campaign from the FBI who is
embedded in there I guess spying on the
Trump campaign now we'll see if any of
this pans out but Tom well we had
confirmation this last week from the
house
the committee that there was a
counterintelligence operation against
Flynn while he was on the campaign or
working for the transit and how does
that play out yes wiretaps are just what
yeah how what was it what did the
program entail look this Justice
Department takes the approach of the
modified limited hangout in terms of
information releases for four months the
Moller operation sat on the fact that
they had the Lisa Paige truck struck
page of messages and on top of that then
we found out about the Clinton DNC
dossier there's going to be a fourth or
a third or fifth shoe to draw their
shoes I mean this I don't believe that
there's classified information at issue
here
there's embarrassing information
addition the stressful part but it's
interesting if if if so I love I know
you love if says they as a white collar
litigator you love my hypotheticals
let's go back to law school
if the FBI embedded someone inside the
Trump campaign and they believed it for
legitimate purpose if Russia was really
trying to throw the election if they had
information indicating that they put
someone inside the Trump campaign were
burrowed away working in a one of those
little cubicles with his ear out or her
ear out what what's the problem there if
there's a problem there oh there's a big
problem unless you have the same kind of
problem you have when you search a
lawyer's office you better have
something really really good to be able
to justify that and here's the problem
there's an old saying and that before I
go any further let's give credit to John
Ehrlichman the author of modified
limited hangout I wouldn't want to leave
him twisting slowly-slowly in the wind
Laura keep in mind there's an old saying
the wages of crying wolf and for me put
her put her finger on it we've now seen
too many instances where the Department
of Justice and/or the FBI has said we
have to redact this because it's it
could endanger national security and
it's classified and we have seen now
time after time where it's been
unredacted and it's just been
embarrassing and the latest exam and
when you do that two or three times
people are going to stop believing you
you lose all credibility and we saw that
last weekend when they finally
unredacted two passages in the House
Intelligence Committee
majority report the Select Committee
report and they revealed two incredible
things one that the FBI didn't think
Mike Flynn had lied we had heard about
that he exactly shocking shockingly that
people haven't focused on enough that
the underlying crime Mike Flynn was
being investigated for was the Logan act
an act that's been a dead-letter for 200
over 200 years all right it's absolutely
shocking but it's really it's really
shocking it's really shocking that Sally
Yates
would would approve and greenlight an
investigation of anybody for violating
the Logan act turkey here I mean we're
way over here but Sally Yates I mean
that little hissy fit of a resignation
letter the show come on she marches
herself over the agents over to
interview Flynn that whole that whole
thing smells like a big fat setup to me
Yates marching what do you have any
business going to interview Mike Flynn
Mike's I didn't even have a lawyer
whether his lecture I'll talk to you
didn't get notice Mike Flynn should have
never talked to them but he didn't think
anything of it Saul he was like well you
know whatever you guys were way over I
want to do an hour with you I need to
have a five hour show I love my guests
thank you guys